weltweit ist trauer und grosser
anteilnahme zu spüren die kerzen und
blumen vor dem buckingham palace in
landen aber auch vor der britischen
botschaft in berlin belegen welchem
platz elisabeth die zweite im herzen so
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger innehatte
auch hier in deutschland
großbritannien hat seine königin
verloren die welt eine jahrhundertfigur
ihre regentschaft erstreckte sich über
mehr als 70 jahre eine halbe ewigkeit
die queen verkörperte das beste unseres
gemeinsamen europäischen erbes
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
ihr leben hat elizabeth zweiter ganz dem
dienst in ihrem land und ihrem volk
gewidmet ihr pflichtbewusstsein war eben
so unerschütterlich wie legendär
deutschland liegt voller dankbarkeit auf
die queen die neben vielen anderen auch
dafür stand dass sich die einstigen
kriegsgegner großbritannien und
deutschland wieder aussöhnen konnten
ihre zahlreichen besucher hier bei uns
waren auch wegen ihrer besonderen
präsenz und zugewandtheit herausragende
ereignisse die bei vielen noch in
erinnerung sind
meine damen und herren ich habe der
britischen premierministerin des trusts
unsere anteilnahme übermittelt auch
deutschland trauert um die britische
königin queen elizabeth ii wir wünschen
ihrem nachfolger schals dem dritten
kraft geschick und das nötige glück für
sein neues amt
vielen dank
dass also das statement von der
bundeskanzlei olaf scholz der mit diesen
worten die königin noch einmal würdigte
und auch die trauer des gesamten landes
die trauer von deutschland zum ausdruck
brachte
[Musik]